In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadion for September 3 on which we commemorate our venerable father
Thoukdistus, fellow ascetic of Saint Athemios the Great.
When he was still very young, our Holy Father Thoukdistus left parents and native land for
the holy places around Jerusalem to devote himself entirely to God.
After venerating the Church of the Resurrection and the precious cross, he withdrew to the
Lavra of Faran, six miles from Jerusalem, where he shut himself in a narrow cell there
to struggle against his passions and against the demons.
At the same time, Athemios left his homeland of Armenia and came to dwell in the same
Lavra.
He emulated Thoukdistus in his ascetic warfare and the two soon became friends in the Lord.
Their mutual love for Christ and their zeal in weaving the crown of glory of the virtues
by ascetic labors bound their hearts so firmly together in spiritual affection that they
had but one thought and one way of life as if they were a single soul in two bodies.
United thus in charity and intention every year at the close of the feast of theophany,
they would go into the wilderness of Kutla away from all dealings with men, desiring nothing
but converse with God through pure prayer in solitude.
There they would remain until Palm Sunday feeding their souls by contemplation and afflicting
their flesh with fasting, vigils, heat and thirst.
In their fifth year at Faran when Thoukdistus and Athemios were, as usual, in the desert
during Lent, they were led by God to a huge cavern set precipitously in the side of a ravine.
The two ascetics were overjoyed at finding this dwelling place built by God and settled
there, subsisting entirely on the plants that grew round about.
The cavern had been a layer of wild beasts but by the prayers and hymns of these two heavenly
men, it was transformed into a church of God.
Their holiness could not long remain hidden and brethren from every land soon flocked to
them, wanting to lead the ascetic life under their direction.
Since Athemios desired solitude above all, he committed every one of those who wanted
to renounce the world to the care of the venerable Thoukdistus, who, perfect in obedience,
followed in all things the council of his friend and father in Christ.
Little by little, this secluded place became a synobium, having the cavern for its church.
Thoukdistus became abbot while Athemios for his part withdrew far into the desert.
So their years passed, they both held fast the bond of charity, Athemios advancing in the
aromatic and Thoukdistus shining in the synobitic life.
Full of years, Thoukdistus fell asleep in the peace of the Lord after a short illness on
the 3rd of September in the year 467.
He was buried by Saint Athemios then 90 years old and by Anastasios, the patriarch of Jerusalem.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.